let's rewind a little bit okay we
introduced this idea of vectors or at
least we introduced that the word
because we said that complex numbers can
be thought of not just as one decimal
expansion but as to do you remember that
it's like it's not enough just to have
one day you need both if you're really
going to express your complex I but
that's what a vector is okay now in
rectangular form what are those two
numbers like the X and the y what do
they actually mean geometrically one day
the X means like it yeah horizontally a
lake and the wine is vertically a height
right so you can talk about horizontal
and vertical displacement and that could
be your pair of numbers okay but much
more common than these two is what we
developed with polar for polar form also
has a pair of numbers but they're not of
our horizontal and vertical displacement
what are they about the two numbers in
polar form yeah a very good direction
which of the numbers gave us direction
which number it's the argument that V
naught that means I'm turning some angle
okay thank you to the direction and then
there's magnitude and we gave that the
name of modules right okay so this
Direction magnitude idea it's what I'm
going to unfollow down in this lesson
now I want you to consider the complex
number a package like that you consider
the complex number 1 plus 2i plus 2i now
we already know we can represent this in
a bunch of ways for instance on this guy
the young complex plane I recall this
the imaginary axis this the real axis
and I could say here's a point is a
point on this plane that represents 1
plus 2i okay let's put some scale on
here so if I said there's one
is one - okay well plus two I would be
yeah okay do you agree with that that's
where I could describe ten now it's not
coordinate one comma two let's call that
now that point paid by itself can
represent what is too much okay but the
idea of a vector set as well how about
we use these okay now on to your diagram
if such as writing pain I'd like you to
draw a vector which represents this
interval with an arrow
okay and you can see how that tells you
magnitude and direction the length of
this tells you the magnitude and which
way it's facing tells your direction
okay so now I've got some inner corner
to you so I can say P the point P that's
one of my representations for what was
to I but I can also say the vector o P
write the vector o P and importantly
you'll notice the direction matters
right the direction is so its own up to
P not paid down to home right opiate
peeper at the same magnitude but they
don't say directions do that does this
make sense so to indicate that I had
this error in here and the order of the
letters really matters to me okay now
here's the thing if direction and
magnitude are the important features
about this at the moment my vector
starts from oh but it doesn't have to
start from Earth it can start anywhere
you like so for instance if I had to
make sure come on it's up to him to move
over events
if I put onto this diagram another pair
of cool limits like say these guns this
one key what's that that's let's call
that hey now neither of these points
represent 1 plus 2i
neither of the points represent 1 plus
2i but being that I can connect a and B
where the direction and magnitude in
other words I can connect them with a
vector that vector I've just drawn the
vector a B that is another equally valid
expression for way of representing 1
plus 2i right it still means translate
one unit to the way and tune it up still
doing the same thing so what I want you
to know it is note the magnitudes are
the same right a b b:a
right those magnitudes are the same
whichever perspective you you're looking
at right but this vector and this vector
are not the same vector they're facing
opposite directions